no there's an impossible day Isaac  family's holding up I think you know  I've been on your side the whole time  and this being a sighs not fun and you  know I just she was an incredible  beautiful girl who didn't hurt anybody  and was decided to go to Italy  bro come overseas and you know  thank you appreciate it what when you  when you look at her and what you know  was in front of her how will you  celebrate her life Stan you know she  helped people she was always there and  she volunteered to coach soccer good  you've been out here all day long how  hard has it been to see these families  and and to be in there and and you were  standing out in front of the bar trying  to call her correct yeah my god